première photo quelle est la quelle
heure quelle est l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
alors quelle est l'actu alors il fait
une percée spectaculaire dans le
classement des personnalités préférées
des Français du JDD il est combien il
est combien je crois qu'il est 7 8e
et oui Grand Corps Malade je suis très
heureux pour lui parce que j'adore cet
artiste et le mérite c'est un homme
formidable et un artiste formidable il
est 8e des personnalités préférées des
Français Jean-Jacques Goldman toujours
numéro 1 on a le producteur on a la
chance d'avoir le producteur de de Grand
Corps Malade
est-ce qu'il peut nous faire une
réaction juste à réaction allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut l'appeler ou pas
on peut pas l'appeler
on attend on a dit on lâche que tu
faisais que ça tu veux toujours me
rajouter
quand même oui c'est pas beaucoup
je voulais l'appeler en fait je
l'appellerai moi t'inquiète d'accord
n'oublie pas merci à bientôt
bonne année bonne année bonne année
bonne année ensemble demain on se voit
après on se voit tout à l'heure on se
voit demain bonne année parce qu'on a
juste un truc qui glisse sur la main
merci voilà merci chérie
donc Jean-Jacques Goldman toujours
personnalité préférée des Français
Thomas Pesquet en et Omar si on prend
parlera de voir si d'ailleurs dans un
instant qui a fait énormément parler
aujourd'hui les chéris attention
deuxième photo le tout en photo c'est
dégueulasse chez vous regardez la photo
c'est de trouver quelle est l'actu c'est
parti
c'est quoi cette actu c'est quoi cette
action
à côté non non non non
[Applaudissements]
alors oui c'est dégueuler j'ai lu j'ai
lu dans la presse régionale qu'un couple
fêtait ses 80 ans de mariage ou quelque
chose comme ça est-ce que ce serait pas
très bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
un couple un couple a fêter cette année
leur sentant chacun et leur 80 ans 80
ans de mariage c'est incroyable non mais
franchement c'est pas beau ça Mathieu
[Rires]
c'est pas Mozart Daniel
deux fois pour une mauvaise attention
jusque-là calme-toi c'est parti regardez
cette troisième photo c'est un
influenceur non non c'est pas celle-là
c'est pas ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon jean pour sortir
je te parle pas alors donc il y a pas de
question à te poser c'est la réponse la
réponse elle a indiqué qu'il lui fallait
35000 euros par mois pour vivre et ça a
fait scandale
[Applaudissements]
exactement jazz qui a dit donc c'est une
star de télé réalité elle a dit qu'il
lui fallait 35000 euros par mois minimum
pour vivre sinon
forcément bah elle s'en sort pas parce
que avec le prix de l'essence quoi mais
c'est fou alors ça ça fait la liste hein
assurance maladie
scolaire on peut pas employer de maison
assurance voiture
aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui sont
vraiment dans le besoin le 10 du mois
c'est très compliqué on parle de
l'électricité on parle des boulangers
qui a qui doivent mettre la clé sous la
porte etc et tu as une jeune femme qui
dit moi j'ai besoin de 35000 bah Olivier
on n'est pas d'accord alors moi ce qui
me choque le plus c'est qu'il est kiffe
choqué c'est hoer déjà et ensuite
au-delà de ça c'est que ces gens là
c'est leur seul fond de commerce c'est
tout ce qu'ils ont à dire c'est je suis
riche je suis blindé j'habite à Dubaï et
je vous emmerde c'est un manque de
respect pour les gens qui les suivent
qui ont pas beaucoup d'argent et en fait
c'est encore une fois la culture du rien
et ce serait bien qu'on donne la parole
en 2023 des ce sont des choses à dire et
pas des gens qui n'ont rien à dire en
fait on demande en avant des gens qui
n'ont rien à dire après
ça va presque c'est pas
une masque de répondre à ça parce qu'ils
adorent ils font que ça toute la journée
de la guerre c'est les followers elle
est suivie par des millions de personnes
donc si les gens se désabonnent d'elle
en fait les gens sont d'accords
de gens qui la suivent ça veut dire que
les gens sont contents d'entendre aussi
c'est vraiment sérieux moi Kelly mais en
fait moi cette année moi je suis vous
avez vu comment je suis gentil
moi je pense pas du tout que ce soit une
vanne c'est très sérieux mais en fait
c'est assumer et en fait elle a elle a
été honnête elle a dit la vérité elle a
pas dit ça pour buzzer elle a pas dit ça
pour en fait on est habitué à ça elle a
toujours montré tout ce qu'elle avait
tout ce qu'elle possédait et on peut
appeler ça un personnage les gens la
suivent pour ça comme disait GG donc
celui dont on peut la suivre et voir un
monde comme ça de richesse et et elle
dit qu'elle a besoin de ça et ben
écoutez suivez-la et continuer et si ça
vous plaît
tu as fini la pâte à crêpes la prochaine
je vais vraiment la réussir mais juste
ça m'agace les hypocrisies de Guillaume
surtout
en régie mais si merci les chéris merci
la photo arrive ils ont plus rien je
crois que Mathieu tattoo Tatum
là
c'est très dur de trouver la réponse
avec qui ils ont mis
mais je veux d'abord jeter mon truc
alors quelle est la faute la réponse
c'est que il y a un mec qui s'est fait
tatouer Messi et puis la regretté de
l'avoir fait 10 jours plus tard c'est
vrai il y a un mec qui fait
on peut voir le tatouage s'il vous plaît
le gars il est pas là avec le dos de la
cuillère le gars il a Messi dit ça veut
dire et il a regretté après c'est un
influenceur et voilà donc maintenant il
a dit
mais qui peut croire à ça regardez mais
c'est pas du tout un vrai temps
alors regardez on a la vidéo regardez
[Applaudissements]
magnifique
de gens qui en Amérique du Sud se sont
fait tatouer Messi
ou alors la Coupe du monde avec Messi et
qui du coup
[Rires]
avec un invité spécial un invité spécial
vous allez devoir trouver ça vaut 3
points
qui est cette personne c'est un invité
spécial
[Applaudissements]
merci vous avez exactement
une minute pour trouver qui est cette
personne merci d'être là comment vous
appelez
Eric merci Eric content
[Rires]
non est-ce que c'est est-ce que par
hasard c'est vous qui aurez reçu le
ballon dans la dans la tête non vous
avez boycoté la Coupe du monde
avant de vous raviser non non il est pas
mal là qu'est-ce que vous avez refusé de
commentaires match non
est-ce que vous avez pas regardé la
finale oui
bravo
[Applaudissements]
la finale de la Coupe du monde mais non
merci Eric merci d'avoir été la fin mais
pourquoi merci merci pourquoi pourquoi
j'ai pas regardé la Coupe du monde parce
que le foot à un moment donné 22 taper
sur un ballon à se faire des millions et
puis toi tu passeras ta vie à jamais
taper dans un ballon et tu feras jamais
le salaire que les métiers font ah non
ça m'intéresse pas
[Applaudissements]
qui gagne la première étoile
tu vas donc faire un selfie avec une
star qui va rentrer dans un instant
[Musique]
qui nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]